[Music]
destiny 2 players alongside myself have
experienced an absolute renaissance and
its sweatiest pvp activity the trials of
osiris the change has been genuinely
unexpected and trials is easily the most
rewarding activity in the game right now
the reward system for the mode has been
completely reworked and we finally
finally have anti-chi if you played
youtube i felt left out of trials or if
you were kind of burnt out on apex
warzone or maybe that call of duty
vanguard beta wasn't quite your cup of
tea then listen up because trials has
something to say
every destiny 2 player knows about
trials of osiris whether we're talking
destiny 1 or the revamped version of
trials of the 9 from the earlier days of
destiny 2. for those out of the loop the
objective in trials is super simple it's
a 3v3 elimination mode that ends once a
team wins a total of five rounds you can
revive your teammates if they die but if
they continue to get picked off then the
cooldown timer on the revive gets
progressively longer after that
objective wins the round teams would go
to a vendor to pick up a passage
basically a scorecard so you can see how
many rounds you've won the ultimate goal
of trials is to go flawless which means
you win 7 full matches in a row not just
the rounds achieving this would unlock
the lighthouse an exclusive social space
but some of the sickest rewards in the
game during the first year of d2 trials
went on hiatus since the game mode
needed serious work bungie stated two
years ago during season of the worthy in
2019 that trials was returning from a
hiatus and that it wouldn't be quote
half baked on arrival spoiler alert it
was half baked as hell apex and warzone
players especially on pc can sympathize
with the d2 folks because cheaters were
everywhere it was maddening even more
demoralizing is you had this like
ridiculous account recovery economy
where high school players would take
money from people to play honor their
accounts and earn them flawless rewards
and that was just booming as a result of
how toxic and almost insulting trials
was at the time the loot was good but
going flawless damn near impossible
unless you had a discord server full of
friends willing to carry you or a ton of
time to spend on heightening your pvp
skills that's all changed with new
alterations to the trials of osiris and
the season of the lost for several
reasons for starters your trials passage
no longer uses your losses to break the
passage before if you got three losses
at any point you could no longer use the
passage and you were forced to reset
starting back at zero the issue in my
mind was that trials matchmaking back in
the day used your card progress as its
main component so if you had a card with
two wins and zero losses the game would
try to put you up against the team with
the same record reset your card and all
of a sudden it's a blind shot as you
were just as likely to face a brand new
team as one that just went flawless and
started a fresh passage now however even
if you lose 10 times in a row if you
still have a couple of wins on your card
those wins will still be counted you
can't go flawless if you have a loss but
winning rounds and matches will still
earn you rewards so flawless isn't your
goal you still will find an incentive to
play and therefore keep the player pool
nice and plentiful going flawless isn't
the only appeal anymore which is huge
for the game mode if you play the game
casually or if you've just ran into some
bad luck with your trials attempts you
will still be rewarded through a
revamped reputation rank system gone are
the days of playing for hours hoping for
a match win just to earn a measly two
tokens and it used to be once you turn
20 you could go to scene 14 and turn
them in just for a new gun but usually
all that work would just lead to him
giving you up in tomorrow's answer
rocket launcher or something turning
your entire effort into a waste of time
now everyone gives you a rank up similar
to how crucible and gambit rank ups work
achieving the next rank will reward you
with the trials engram straight up which
you can decrypt into a random drop if
you have some shards and glimmer on hand
you can spend that to focus the engram
into something specific that you've
already unlocked in hopes of achieving
that high stat or god roll that you've
always wanted another cool change is
that your passage doesn't end once
you've gone flawless see there is a huge
incentive now to keep playing on a
flawless card because every game one
after you've gone flawless has a chance
of dropping lighthouse level rewards
that's right higher level players no
longer need to keep resetting their
cards and getting tossed back into the
matchmaking pool on some poor
unsuspecting newcomers now in my case i
made the mistake of turning in my
passage after the first flawless of the
weekend and had to recline but the
moment my second trip to the lighthouse
was complete i kept playing with my team
and we got more added lighthouse tier
rewards in like 30 minutes than i had
for the entire six hours leading up to
that final run in the past lower level
teams would just constantly get stomped
on and eventually they'd quit trials
altogether dramatically shifting the
matchmaking pool now even if you go in
and are basically a punching bag for
streamers and pro gamers you still have
a lot of opportunity to obtain some
extremely quality loot of course you
won't be racking in the add-up flawless
weapons as often if at all but
high-level players are also no longer
gatekeeping the loot either the high
barrier of entry to get even a single
reward is no longer a factor if you
can't find a group you can now hop into
trial solo to mix results depending on
the new skill based matchmaking system
if your goal is flawless you still want
to group for sure because your odds of
success going in solo are dramatically
lower now i'm sure there will be
outliers but the overwhelming sentiment
online is that running trials solo is a
very mixed bag but let's focus on the
fact that it's even a possibility which
is huge and is a huge boon for groups as
it means a larger matchmaking pool
before these changes the flawless loot
that you would receive was kind of
whatever too since once you got your
weapon and emblem there was like this
okay what now type situation a few
seasons ago adapt weapons were
introduced which were supposed to make
the flawless rewards meaningful and
encouraged teams to see their cards all
the way through versus playing up to
whatever loot dropped at the three win
five win or seven win benchmarks and
then just resetting their cards now that
skill based matchmaking is a factor it's
less likely that you're gonna face the
usual streamers or the dudes with the
2500 plus elo rating this weekend a lot
of my friends made it to flawless for
the first time and their overall katie's
were well under 1.0 and that is a good
thing i've seen a lot of folks on
twitter complain about skill-based
matchmaking and they're not the pros or
the average players they're usually the
dudes that made a killing by charging
for recoveries and then just stomping on
weaker players and now they actually
have to work for it they're starting to
quake a little bit some of the pro
players though like gigs on the other
hand know their own skill level and are
confident that having a harder challenge
is totally fine and they're still
excited to see players who used to be on
the outside looking in get their
legitimate shot at making it to the
lighthouse that's why everyone needs to
play trials as soon as they can keep the
game mode filled to the brim with
players and earn some sick rewards while
you're at it the messenger and igneous
hammer are two superb guns for all
around crucible play within the current
meta and they can even drop with the
newer perks that have only just come out
this season which makes the sandbox real
interesting to play around with i know
everyone loves kill clip but that gets
boring we've said for years to bungee
that we don't just want more loot we
want better and more interesting loot
since more loot simply means more
garbage in the vault and having the new
perks roll on the trials weapons while
letting players cough up some extra
materials to focus their drops leads to
less clutter more useful rewards and
better payout now here's the best part
of trials right now without a doubt
battlely the anti-cheat system is doing
what it's advertised to do and it's
looking real nice i'm sure there's some
cheating scum doing their damnedest to
get around destiny 2's anti-cheat but as
of right now i cannot tell you how
relieving it is to get killed and go
damn great snipe instead of having no
choice but to second guess and go
maybe they have wall hacks having games
go down to the wire for one team or
another to win always ends in either the
team going damn fair play that was a
really good game or just emphatic
shouting if you pull off the dub you
have to understand how huge that
sentiment is because not too long ago
getting stomped in trials felt like a
self-fulfilling prophecy you expected to
lose and you just resigned yourself to
it i've spent so much time begging my
friends to join me in trials and
literally no one wanted to do it or they
would go in and just go eh i'm just here
for the weekly bounty because the game
mode simply wasn't fun that's all
changed now and if you're playing
destiny 2 and always wistfully looked at
the dude rocking the glowing trials
armor in the tower now is your chance to
blaze your own path to the lighthouse
and if going flawless still isn't quite
within reach then it's perfectly fine
because now you have every opportunity
and right to still take part and take
home some sweet loot rewards there's a
lot of other popular shooters out there
that are kind of hitting a dip whether
it's from player fatigue or from a
myriad of other reasons like the
incredible amount of cheaters and
warzone but destiny 2's endgame pvp is
in a really nice place right now and
it's only going to get better if you
haven't yet give the game a try you'll
want to be as high of a power level as
possible to access trials but the usual
grind for power is not nearly as
imposing as it used to be and getting up
to speed is faster than ever there's a
whole lot of content in destiny 2 right
now so you'll have something to chew on
for quite a bit as you build your
guardian into a pvp machine make no
mistake the changes made to trials of
osiris are amazing the revamp reward
system is top notch stocking up on
materials actually matters now if you
want to focus your loot drops and the
availability of the mode to solo players
opens up the floodgates to keeping the
player population high a must for an
endgame pinnacle activity that wants to
have enough varied matches there have
been so many uplifting stories on
twitter about people getting their first
flawless and for me personally i made it
to the lighthouse a whopping five times
on pc this weekend compared to only two
times in the last year and i was even
able to help lift several of my friends
who had never made it before and one of
those flawlesses was on a passage of
confidence which for those of you who
know that is ridiculous
dude is that your
flawless or what oh yeah [ __ ] yeah let's
go
oh yeah it was without doubt the best
weekend of destiny 2 i had ever played
in my last 4 years and for someone with
over 2 000 hours in this game that's
saying something
[Music]
this is tom hussein reading for reviewer
richard wakeling like most detective
stories lost judgment begins with a
ghastly discovery of a maga infested
corpse a single homicide is merely the
tip of the iceberg of course but the
unusual circumstances surrounding the
dead body's discovery set the stage for
another compelling mystery for private
investigator takayuki yagami to solve
his latest adventure still dips its feet
into the deep end of the criminal
underworld but lost judgment distances
itself from its yakuza flavoured origins
with much more regularity than its
predecessor resulting in a better more
distinct game that still tinge with an
over sense of deja vu
[Music]
this begins right from the off as the
first hour or so was spent traversing
the well-worn streets of kamurocho
revisiting the bustling red light
district for the umpteenth time still
doesn't grow stale thanks to its lively
atmosphere and intricate visual design
it's a place full of fond memories and
there's a pleasant sense of comfort in
its familiarity yet it's hard not to
feel relieved when yagami's latest case
takes you south of tokyo and to the port
city of yokohama the fictional district
of isezaki ijinsho was first introduced
in last year's yakuza like a dragon and
makes its return in lost judgment
relatively untouched it's a bigger urban
sprawl than kaimurocho but still
maintains the same density step through
the automatic doors of a pop-up store
and you'll be greeted by a short
electronic tune that announces your
arrival the magazine aisle is stacked
with lifestyle magazines manga and
cookbooks while the refrigerators at the
back of the store are filled with
assorted snacks elsewhere you can head
to the bar district to find each cozy
hangout stocked with real world alcohol
while passing beneath the pai fang in
chinatown will lead you to restaurants
adorned with dragons and golden guardian
lions there are club sega arcades where
you can play the likes of virtua fighter
5 final showdown space harrier and even
the ill-advised sonic fighting game
sonic the fighters
[Music]
if none of these tickle your fancy
there's another sequel to the pseudo
house of the dead sequel introduced in
judgement this time it's called hammer
of the dead a fully fledged light gun
shooter that sees zombies invade the
streets
outside of the hypnotic lights of the
arcade you can also play shogi and
mahjong battled against ai opponents in
a mario party svr board game compete in
drone races hit home runs at the batting
cages or simply befriend the
neighborhood cats this is all par for
the course in an rgg studio game but the
sheer breadth of diversions is still
staggering especially when so much of
them are genuinely enjoyable and this
love of distractions bleeds into lost
judgment's main narrative too yagami and
his best friend slash business partner
masaharu kaito get a call from their old
pals fumia sugira and makoto tsukumo
about some work in yokohama the case
which revolves around bullying
allegations at a local high school
sounds delicate but easy enough for a
seasoned pro but it gradually expands
into an intricate web that focuses on
the frailties of the justice system and
how law and order can be so easily
manipulated heavy themes such as
bullying suicide and sexual battery are
handled with a death touch required of
such topics and it even does an
excellent job of making you feel empathy
for characters that have committed
heinous acts by shrouding everything in
grey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
moments of levity between the core cast
of friends ensure that it's not always
completely bleak although kaito takes
more of the back seat this time around
leaving yagami to carry most of the
emotional load fortunately he's still an
endearing and immediately likable
protagonist with a strict set of morals
and a steely sense of determination
that's only offset by his quick wit he
doesn't need to wrestle with as many
demons as he did in the first game and
his character development is
surprisingly light but yagami is no less
delightful to be around
lost judgment is heartfelt and
sentimental at times too even if these
moments can be a tad melodramatic but
that's to be expected if there are any
failings with the story it's that the
script can be unnecessarily verbose at
times constantly regurgitating
information you're already well aware of
aside from this however the core mystery
is frequently gripping with plenty of
unsuspecting twists and turns a devious
villain and intense moments that
guarantee you'll be perched on the edge
of your seat for the long run the high
school setting goes a long way towards
differentiating judgment from the other
rgg studio games as well the main
through line eventually leaves the score
behind but that doesn't mean you have to
in order to stay at school and continue
his investigation yagami becomes an
outside advisor for the school's mystery
club students in this extracurricular
clique usually sit around reading
sherlock holmes stories and other
mystery novels but with the yagami
involved they set their sights a lot
higher it doesn't take long before
you're infiltrating various student
groups in order to unveil information
about a nefarious figure known as the
professor this elaborate side case
doesn't have anything to do with the
main story but with the setting and
characters often overlapping it all
feels interconnected and cohesive no
matter how disparate both cases are from
each other you start by helping students
perfect their craft in the dance club
which features a rhythm minigame and a
pop and locking journey to the nationals
[Music]
after this there's a robotics club where
you help engineer a fleet of robotics
and compete in competition for territory
control there's an entirely new combat
style for your fights in the boxing gym
that also comes complete with its own
separate upgrade tree and a plethora of
opponents for you to jab and hook into
submission you can also give tony hawk a
run for his money by getting involved in
a power struggle between two rival
skateboarding crews aside from adding a
veritable bucket load of variety most of
these school cases are surprisingly
comprehensive it's easy to suck up hours
of fine-tuning your robot or barreling
through the competition in the esports
club and each one features an engaging
conspiracy for you to uncover that feeds
into the overarching narrative and this
is on top of the usual slew of absurd
side missions rgg studios excels at
unfortunately yagami's investigative
repertoire is mostly unchanged from the
first game tailing missions are
mercifully less frequent this time
around and those that do exist are
slightly shorter which does alleviate
some of the arduousness there are still
plenty of on-rails chase sequences
though which are as monotonous and stale
as before occasionally you'll need to
search scenes for clues but this process
is little more than an ostentatious
pixel hunt and there are no fail states
involved when you have to present
evidence or engage in lines of
questioning so these moments lack any
real player agency parkour is a new
addition that's easy scaling pipes and
leaping across gaps to reach places
yagami isn't supposed to be there are
also a few instances of rudimentary
stealth but these sections are so
stiflingly linear that it essentially
holds your hand to the point where
you're barely even playing you're still
here to accompany yagami rather than
deduce anything yourself that doesn't
mean there aren't plenty of
opportunities to kick people's teeth in
however yagami is still adept at his own
curious brand of kung fu with both the
crane and tiger styles returning from
the first game snake style is a new
addition that specializes in disarming
enemies and countering attacks
all three styles are ostensibly designed
for specific situations crane excels at
crowd control while tiger is used to
deal heavy damage to a single target but
this isn't a strict rule and mostly
comes down to personal preference and
how much you want to shake things up
combat is as hard-hitting and as
satisfying as ever particularly once you
throw in some devastating ex moves and
it also feels surprisingly fresh off the
back of yakuza like a dragon's shift to
turn-based combat
lost judgment improves on its
predecessor by cutting down on some of
the more tedious elements of its design
rather than outright changing the
mechanics to make the investigative side
of the equation more engaging in this
sense it's disappointing that it doesn't
lean into what makes judgment unique
compared to the yakuza series and
instead remains at his best when
sticking close to those origins the
story is compelling with an endearing
cast of characters the sheer amount of
stuff to do is astounding and there's
still an inherent joy that comes from
pummeling the city's delinquents into
the ground but it's hard not to feel
disappointed that you still feel like a
passenger when it breaks away from the
yakuza mold if this is indeed our last
time with yagami and ko then it's one to
cherish but there'll always be that
nagging feeling that this was a missed
opportunity to do something truly
special
[Music]
breath of the wild discoveries continue
to occur no matter how much we think
they're going to slow down players seem
to push the game's limits even farther
blss or bow lift smuggling slide is one
of the biggest new additions to the ever
growing list of discoveries found in the
legend of zelda breath of the wild while
wind bombs and bullet time bounces are
still a staple form of travel for casual
players and speedrunners alike blss
offers a new way of long distance travel
without too much setup needed if you
enjoy a breath of the wild content make
sure to like this video as we continue
to cover this game still to this day
the story behind this discovery as with
most breath of the wild finds begins
with the glitch hunters bouncing ideas
off each other through twitter the most
recent trend was people finding new ways
to smuggle a technique of making link
hold items he's not supposed to japanese
user pd conten then found this strange
smuggle that led to link holding a bow
and an object at the same time glitch
hunter legend of link then decided to
mess with this find as well and on
september 4th found that by doing this
glitch holding b then mounting a small
ledge will cause link to levitate and
glide at incredible speeds so now you're
wondering if you could do it for
yourself you can and it's pretty easy
i'll teach you first how to do for
yourself at home then for the more
hardcore audience explain the mechanics
behind how this works
all you need to perform this glitch is a
shield a bow a liftable object such as a
bomb and a small ledge to step up on
first place a bomb or object in front of
link then hold zl to bring up only his
shield in front and no weapon in his
hand then press z r and a in quick
succession
this should be fairly easy as you'll see
link holders bow then lift the object
with the bow still in his hands the next
part is slightly harder as you'll have
to jump press b then pause as fast as
possible the succession of b to pause
needs to be pretty quick but holding zl
while doing this makes the process a
little bit easier especially with larger
objects then from the pause menu unequip
your shield
now simply aim your bow and then press b
from this point hold b then approach any
small ledge and step up over it going
over it will cause you to start hovering
above the ground keep in mind that you
absolutely must hold down any walking
direction down at all times as letting
go of the stick and that releasing b
will also cause link to fall try out
different items as every object
interacts differently with how link
moves to maximize on this technique
though the bomb version is the most
controllable tilting the left joystick
directly left to right quickly with the
held object towards the camera you can
cause link to gain speed quickly all in
all it might take a couple tries but
it's not too difficult to pull off
now for people wondering about the
technical magic behind this i'll explain
as best as possible but don't be too
discouraged if this part confuses you as
you don't need to understand this to
perform the glitch anyways
this is a succession story of several
glitches being combined together first
why is it even called bow lift smuggling
slide well it's incorporating both a
normal bow smuggle and an item lift
smuggle at the same time and when you
perform this glitch you also trigger
another glitch called b-lock which has a
side effect called bose lighting hence
why it's called faux lift smuggling
slide or blss okay crazy acronym aside
what exactly are these glitches and why
is this happening let's go a little more
in depth when link performs a step up
animation link goes from walking on the
ground then stepping up then walking on
the ground again pretty simple but
stepping up while bose sliding causes
this strange locked state of never
finishing a step up meaning he's in a
limbo state of actually never being on
solid ground but since blss is a
combination of both sliding and
smuggling when link steps up he is
forcefully pushed out of his normal step
up onto an invisible layer while
actually never finishing his animation
okay interesting but what makes link
move so strangely and how is it getting
pushed around that's where the smuggling
comes in there's two versions found so
far of smuggling a liftable object in
breath of the wild one method causes
collision with objects away from link as
if link were heavier the other method
pushes link away from the object as if
link were lighter this is why this
glitch has incredible movement
capabilities while holding the object
like this the object itself is pushing
itself into link's hitbox causing this
movement in the air any quick movement
aggravates the held object to push link
more and more causing you to gain
massive speed while doing this trick
because the object is constantly nudging
into link over and over while floating
with no friction to stop him this all
combined gives link infinite flight in
breath of the wild
in any case understanding all the insane
mechanics isn't really necessary but
understanding is positive and negatives
is such as the amazing infinite distance
capability with absolutely no stamina
needed from gliding compared to other
techniques and no health required
compared to techniques such as wind
bombs but blss by itself has no ability
to gain height upwards and there's a
possibility of actually going too fast
and hitting breath of the wild's
built-in speed cap which will cause link
to slow down back to a crawl or even
stop him dead in his tracks and fall
down but despite the positives and
negatives is this glitch fun to do
absolutely you should give it a shot and
zoom across hyrule yourself it's loads
of fun
[Music]
if you simply want to see blss in action
stick around now to see me cross the
entire map in roughly four minutes with
this amazing trick and of course for
everything else breath of the wild stick
right here on gamespot
one more note before i leave you to the
scenic flight if you want to do what i'm
doing don't pan the camera around too
much like i did on this trip it's mostly
for your viewers to get some decent
views during the trip this will often
cause more loading lag as you travel so
for the least amount of lag try not to
turn the camera too much okay enjoy
that
[Music]
[Music]
so
hey
[Music]
[Music]
we've finally seen more of god of war
ragnarok at sony's september playstation
showcase developer sony santa monica has
revealed a bunch of info about the game
so here's everything we know so far for
more videos on god of war make sure to
like this video and subscribe and beware
spoilers ahead for the end of god of war
2018.
yes as the name suggests ragnarok the
fabled end of the world in norse
mythology is coming and kratos and
atreus are desperately trying to stop it
but it's not gonna be an easy task
kratos and atreus got pretty entangled
in the norse gods affairs in god of war
and made many enemies along the way that
they'll now have to deal with as well as
trying to stop the end of the world they
killed baldur son of freya and odin and
a once friendly freya is out for revenge
according to santa monica studio we
wanted to remind players that freyja
isn't just a terrifyingly powerful user
of vania magic but also that she's a
formidable warrior in her own right
enraged by kratos's evasion of justice
by her hand freya will turn every weapon
at her disposal towards her son's killer
are you a calm and reasonable person
we also caught a glimpse of thor in the
post-credits of god of war looking for
you guessed it revenge for the death of
his sons modi and magni and his
half-brother balder santa monica said
thor's legendary bloodlust and wrath
will be aimed at kratos and atreus
referred to disparagingly by mimir as
the biggest butchering bastard in the
nine realms thor earned his title as one
of the most powerful asia gods by wiping
out nearly all the giants at odin's
command now if this doesn't sound like
the thor you know i seriously recommend
picking up neil gaiman's norse mythology
for a primer on
this thor let's just say he's uh
something else entirely is he though and
speaking of giants like i said they're
not exactly the all father odin's
favorites and he has long been at war
with them he had thor try and wipe them
out and he imprisoned his other son tyr
for helping them now we believe tyr to
be dead in the first game but it looks
like we're going to be meeting him in
ragnarok the giants had the gift of
foresight and at the end of god of war
kratos uncovered a prophecy where it was
revealed that his wife was actually a
giant named lauthy not only is atreus
part giant he was also given the name
loki at birth and is somehow involved in
ragnarok so much for not getting
involved in the aco's affairs you're
with regard to atreus santa monica
studio revealed that like most young
people he wants to understand who he is
more than anything in this case he wants
to understand who he could be the
mystery of loki's role in the upcoming
conflict is something that detroit
cannot let go of he wants to keep his
family safe but atreus also doesn't want
to stand by and do nothing while
conflict consumes the nine realms
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there finding out who i
am who loki is but the usually
bloodthirsty kratos seems to wish to
take a different path a line from the
game's description insinuates that he is
intent on helping to spare atreus from
the bloody lessons he learned from his
conflict with gods he wants to keep his
son safe above all and their
confrontation with baldur has vindicated
the belief that only tragedy will come
from further entanglements with the
aesir together kratos and atreus will
have to make a choice about which path
they will take whatever they choose will
define the fate of all those living in
the nine realms as ragnarok approaches
which leads us quite nicely into combat
2018's god of war was praised for its
crunchy combat mechanics and systems and
sony santa monica has pledged to carry
forward that spirit and tradition
as a team we've worked hard to take our
learnings from god of war 2018 and
improve upon combat to feel fresh yet
familiar with god of war ragnarok one of
our main goals was to push player choice
in combat whether it's through hard
hitting combos a mastery of elements or
clever defensive tactics you will find
plenty of opportunities to fight
alongside our duo in a way that feels
uniquely expressive which is great
because not only do you have gods on
your tail but the other enemies in
ragnarok will be harsher and more varied
with kratos and atreya set to take on a
host of new creatures from across norse
mythology some of the new enemies
revealed so far include the stalker and
the drachi
whereas 2018's god of war allowed
players to visit six of the nine realms
ragnarok goes further and takes you to
all nine this includes vanaheim
svartalfheim and asgard which were not
in the first game new areas from
previous locations have been added to
ragnarok as well according to santa
monica studios exploring the realms will
take you everywhere from verdant
otherworldly jungles to intricate
subterranean mining networks this next
installment in the series will bring you
a more diverse beautiful and mysterious
variety of locations than in any other
god of war game
christopher judge and sunny soljic
returned to voice kratos and atreus
while ryan hirst who played opie in sons
of anarchy has joined the cast as thor
leia de leon hayes plays anger border
while ben prendergast portrays tear
richard schiff will be playing odin
[Music]
returning from the 2018 game is bear
mccreary to once again compose the music
the new trailer from the playstation
showcase includes a tease of the new
tunes and according to mccreery's
twitter it includes a significant new
character theme which sounds both very
ominous and very exciting
corey barlog directed 2018's god of war
as well as 2007's god of war 2 but he's
not returning to direct the sequel
stepping in is eric williams a veteran
of the series to direct ragnarok
speaking to vgc williams said it's
always been a tradition here at santa
monica to change the directors across
the games we've had really good success
with that corey is the only repeat
director and rightfully so he's damn
good at what he does corey barlock added
the important thing for us is to be able
to get a fresh perspective each time but
also a fresh pair of legs in the sense
that you're really exhausted at the end
of finishing one of these things so
you've got to con somebody else into
doing it now you are ready
[Music]
god of war ragnarok is planned for ps5
but it's also coming to ps4 the news of
a previous gen version was quietly
shared via a q a with hermann holst the
head of playstation studios at the
september playstation showcase sony
confirmed that ragnarok will be released
across ps5 and ps4 although there is no
word yet on any big differences between
the editions that might exist
and what about pc well this is all
speculative right now given sony's
recent track record of slowly bringing
some of its biggest playstation games to
pc it does make sense to question the
possibility for a pc version of god of
war ragnarok sony also recently acquired
the pc port specialist nix's software
fueling rumors that it might bring more
of its first party games to pc to help
expand their audience while a pc edition
of ragnarok hasn't been confirmed yet
halst mentioned in an interview on the
playstation blog that the company
continues to further invest in the pc
space but if it's anything like previous
sony releases on pc it's likely not to
come to the platform for some time if it
ever does
we'll let you know when we do
if you're interested in a the scenes
look at how the 2018 god of war was made
check out our episode of audio logs
where game director corey barlog breaks
down one of the most pivotal scenes how
it was created and the crucial gameplay
mechanic that was almost cut from the
game
and we really had to figure out how to
take the old moves and make them work
much better in this camera angle for
more god of war make sure to like this
video and subscribe and we'll catch you
next time
you'll get your answer soon enough
well some of them
[Music]
death loop's black reef changed the way
i play games and made me behave in a way
that's not in my nature the role i
inhabit is that of a ghost entering a
scenario to achieve an objective and
leaving with clean hands and conscience
i'm the pebble thrown into water that
makes no ripples and yet in death loop i
murdered hundreds of eternalists and i
felt good about doing it the allele of
black reefs daily absolution which wipes
the slate clean for each new time loop
was difficult to resist and killing
became second nature but this leads you
to ask when nothing matters how do you
give your actions meaning that's where
developer arcane leon's gameplay design
comes into play and killing with abandon
becomes killing for a reason to break
the loop
that was one
ridiculous nightmare
ah i gotta stop drinking
the mechanics of death loop are
constructed so masterfully that there's
a tangible sense of growth both in game
and out of it but what's most impressive
about death loop is that it's also an
introspective game it's arcane
deconstructing its own brand of
open-ended action the systems are
presented as digestible and the game
subtly pushes you to put the pieces
together so you can truly appreciate how
it all ticks it's a game where
observation and dynamic thinking go hand
in hand with shotgunning goons in the
face and it delivers bombastic thrillers
with intelligence and elegance in equal
measure at the heart of the game is colt
vaughan a man simultaneously adrift in
time and stuck within it he wakes up on
a beach with no memory of how he got
there or what's really going on however
what distinguishes him from the other
hedonistic denizens of black roof is
that he's able to retain his memory
between loops and very soon he discovers
that a strange element called residueum
can be harnessed to give his arsenal of
weaponry and supernatural abilities
permanence too death loop is a
fascinating mashup of styles and vibes
underpinning the world is a kind of
retro future science that is incredibly
effective at giving the world texture
think time travel by way of 1960s
computers that fill a room and look like
they have less power than an original
iphone complementing that is an element
of the supernatural that is essentially
time science harnessed by a mad genius
to give a chosen few the ability to do
things like teleport link the fate of
other people together
or become almost invisible amongst other
things these abilities are bestowed to
the visionaries an eclectic group of
elites that the rank and file are sworn
to protect so that their life of
indulgence can remain eternal cult's
goal is to kill these visionaries and in
doing so break the time loop the rob is
that it needs to be done in one day a
single loop easier said than done given
that the game operates on a night and
day cycle where over the course of the
loop each visionary has their own
routine and life to lead complicating
matters further is the fact that the
visionaries know cult is out to get them
and in fact all of them have some sort
of pre-existing relationship with him
[Music]
one in particular juliana takes it upon
herself to be the thorn in colt's side
she serves the role of antagonist but
the situation is clearly complicated
between them their interpersonal dynamic
is placed front and center to drive much
of the narrative and characterization
and both characters are realized
exceptionally well juliana is the voice
in colt's air and also over blackreach's
loudspeakers and she does her damn this
to get under his skin she picks at him
in a way that only someone with a deep
personal connection to you can using
insight into his personality and history
to constantly undermine him and poke at
his neuroses and yet there's also a
sweetness to their interactions at times
like a couple in the heat of an argument
remembering for just a moment why they
care about each other in a very real
sense juliana is a pure agent of chaos
it's worth pointing out that the voice
acting is absolutely crucial to selling
this relationship and in that regard
it's achieved exceptionally well i'm
done playing this your way it's the cult
show from now on
okay
all aboard sweetie
i said colt show not cold for his part
colt eventually engages her in the
verbal joust and starts getting under
her skin the constant back and forth
between the two is a genuine joy to
listen to and the writing is sharp to
make their development of their
relationship feel natural black reef is
split up into multiple districts and
each one is usually home to at least one
of the visionaries colt's objective is
to enter an area figure out how to get
himself into a position where he can
kill said visionary and take their slab
an item that gives them one of six
unique supernatural abilities but each
of the visionaries is
a weirdo charlie for example has set up
a low budget escape room harriet is
hosting a group of wellness sessions
that is as sinister as it sounds while
wenji rarely ever leaves her lab death
loops day and night cycle also means
that these visionaries are only
available at certain times of the day
although you can manually progress time
to your needs there's only ever a
specific window of opportunity to kill a
visionary that means you need to play
through time loops repeatedly puzzling
out a plan to execute it when a time is
right the game makes this more
manageable by giving the player
visionary leads to follow you may need
the code to a door in one area for
example but a ledger with that
information is being stored in an office
elsewhere so you also kind of get a tour
of black reef through this you're slowly
trained to develop a meticulous
understanding of each area in the game
and as your cult grows in strength and
capabilities so too does your
proficiency in navigating them after
killing a visionary you gain a power
which can be used in the following time
loops provided you invest residium into
them residium can be extracted from
charged objects in the environment or
from the dead body of a visionary
spending this resource allows you to
hold on to tools between loops slab
powers are the most essential as they
give you a significant ability and
killing a visionary repeatedly to take
their slab will evolve the power the
shift power for example lets you
teleport much like dishonest blink but
repeatedly killing the visionary
wielding it and collecting it will allow
you to upgrade the power to let you swap
places with an enemy
trinkets are also littered throughout
the world weapon trinkets can be used to
augment your combat abilities while
personal trinkets enhance colt's
physical performance the presence of
these is what makes each time loop
consistently rewarding to play through
sometimes it can be good to do a run
through an area or even entire loop to
build your resilient balance and collect
some more trinkets especially since it's
also an opportunity to refine your
chosen playstyle a bit more and since
cult is able to come back from death
twice there is a degree of forgiveness
in the game that really encourages you
to do wacky things when the opportunity
arises that third death however will
reset the time loop entirely so some
strategy is also required if you want to
make the most of your time the
repetition based design of death loop
eases you into creating a flow state
that you can enter into and exit from at
will with the character development
system it gamifies trial and error so
effectively that failures almost always
still feel like small triumphs this
might sound typical of a roguelike game
but death loop's gameplay feels entirely
of its own brand and that's because it's
built on the foundation of arcane's
domino effect design that is especially
apparent as you uncover dead ends
documents peppered around the world will
provide a small lead on something which
is then marked as a discovery and the
game does an excellent job of creating a
breadcrumb trail around black reef for
you to follow and it always leads to
something meaningful whether it's
finding the code to open a locked door
or figuring out how to manipulate two
visionaries into appearing at the same
place at the same time you're never more
than a run or two away from having an
epiphany in many regards death loop is a
game about being meticulous and arcane
has done a fantastic job in making the
act of just being in the world looking
around and listening to it enthralling
it should come as no surprise that black
reef is absolutely stunning to behold
given the strong sense of art direction
that the studio's previous games have
had each of the four areas of the game
has a distinct style which changes
depending on the time of day thanks to
lighting and even weather effects of
particular note are the 60s esque
interiors that are somehow both
beautiful and utterly garish in a way
that only retro furniture can be wooden
walls shocking red pleather couches that
look like they would make your ass numb
after a minute of sitting on them and
oddly contorted lighting fixtures will
stop you in your tracks so you can ogle
at how odd they are but they also fit
into the aesthetic so perfectly that you
can't help but be impressed by the
interior design chops being displayed
needless to say arcane sense of art
direction remains impeccable and for my
money unmatched and complementing it is
the raucous soundtrack that is as
eclectic and as unexpected as the visual
stylings continuing the mashup of styles
and themes death loop transitions
effortlessly between disparate styles to
suit the needs of the moment from a
cinematic standpoint but also has you
tapping your feet along to the chaos
happening on screen death loop's gun
play is weighty and satisfying and a
great deal of the thrill that comes from
trading lead is elevated by the
brilliant funky soundtrack
the final piece to death loop's gameplay
puzzle is multiplayer which manifests
itself in two distinct ways the first is
technically not multiplayer as it sees
an ai controlled juliana invade colt's
game to try and assassinate him at
random points the game announces that
juliana has invaded and locked the exit
points out of the area the only way to
get out is hack a specific point
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
living in america
is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
right
oh
[Music]
hey everybody what's up and welcome to
thq nordic's first digital showcase to
celebrate their 10th anniversary they
wanted to share some exciting
announcements and updates with you i'm
jeff keeley and as we've all just seen
thq nordic is bringing back earth's
favorite destroyer crypto for another
round of earth-shattering anal probing
human annihilating madness this time in
the 60s and destroy all humans too
kryptos got his eyes on taking over more
than just america with new easy breezy
weapons of mass destruction
greetings mother russia
mines
it's all a haze man who was this little
green dude then he had this like big gun
and a jet pack and he really showed the
man whose boss tossed the fuzz around
and boom
[Music]
call himself krypto
i think
so they put on those groovy glasses and
suddenly it was all colors and i just
wanted to dance man like couldn't have
stopped if i wanted
[Music]
[Music]
like they're just marshmallows man
[Music]
really far out
soon the citizens of bay city will be
embarking on a very bad trip
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh is that right
[Laughter]
now our next title took a 22 year hiatus
after its award-winning debut that's
right appeal studios is bringing back
outcast if you don't know the original
outcast because in 1999 your feet didn't
touch the ground when you sat in a
normal sized chair or if you played it
and loved it but you've slept once or
twice in 22 years here's a refresher you
play cutter a former u.s navy seal
stranded on an alien planet an outcast
to a new beginning your job is to join
the talons and fight against invading
robotic soldiers you'll come equipped
with your jet pack to travel across the
alien world and will be able to
customize your weapon to blast your
enemies adelpha is under attack and it's
your job to lead the uprising
[Music]
ever since the ancients left us
and as far as the moons remember
adelpha has been under ataland's care
[Music]
we are the keepers of all yards
creations
we are home
renounce false prophecies
and give faith
to our makers
[Music]
if the odds can't save us
no one will
so
[Music]
so
so
this
is my home
my planet
[Music]
adelpha
ever since i was a girl
[Music]
i wanted to become
a dolotai guardian
[Music]
to protect adelpha
and all its creatures
big and small
virtuous and vicious
to defend against those
who want to exploit its beauty
[Music]
and
destroy it
[Music]
but now
[Music]
we face our greatest threat
[Music]
we need
all the help we can get
cutter slade your friendly neighborhood
invader slayer
[Music]
different planet same problems
in the latest game in the expedition
series you'll play a roman leggett the
commanding officer of a legion your
companions will live fight and
potentially die at your command lead
your army through greece north africa
and gaul to earn respect or fear meet
powerful leaders pacify provinces gather
resources and care for your legionaries
play as a male or female hero ladies of
rome why not go rewrite history in
expeditions rome the die is not yet cast
very good stay here i have the best
throwing arm
raise the alarm
romans are within the city walls
hello everyone
i'm jonas veva and i'm senator we're
from logic artists working on our news
game expeditions rome
expedition's rome is a tactical
turn-based role-playing game set in the
ancient roman republic right around the
time of julius caesar
the game casts you as a young roman
noble who is forced to flee rome and you
seek refuge in a legion
where you'll rise through the ranks and
eventually assume commander of the
legion yourself as as legate
in our game combat takes place on a hex
grid where you buy for strategic
positions to overwhelm your enemy
we focused on giving each unit a wide
range of skills to choose from that
allows you to really try different
things and find your own way to tackle
each encounter
yeah our goal with designing the combat
system was to make you feel like a small
elite group of professional roman
soldiers facing off against the
barbarian hordes
you are very well equipped you're very
well trained you have to experiment with
your skills some of which come from your
weapons and others of which come from
your classes
and find the best way that your
characters can work together to survive
in the face of these overwhelming arts
ultimately it's a role-playing game and
the most important thing to us is to
give you a strong deep story full of
memorable characters some of which are
from real history because our game is
set in the real world right around the
end of the roman republic
our story spans a decade and it takes
you all across europe including of
course to rome herself
what i really like though is our
approach to choices and consequences
there's a real sense of the world
reacting to what you're doing and the
role you decide to play
choices and consequences are a huge deal
to us we've spent a lot of time and
effort making sure that even small
actions you take can have surprisingly
large knock-on effects
decisions you make right at the start of
the story can come back multiple times
throughout your adventures
don't kill him
he deserves worse faith than that
he should try being serious himself
killing him is the safest option
he clearly holds a lot of sway in this
region the locals might try to rescue
him if we keep him alive
this is by far the biggest game we've
worked on so far it is more than twice
the size of our previous game in the
series and we talked on a few things in
the game but we haven't even touched on
the majority of the features like
managing and commanding your legion in
battle crafting items leveling and
equipping your party or treating the
injuries after a fight or expanding your
war camp to unlock new features we
haven't even talked about the music
either our composer tom farnham has done
a fantastic job of bringing to life all
of these diverse cultures and again
absolutely i still get the chills
whenever i listen to the main theme the
main theme is wonderful
another of my favorites is cleopatra's
theme because somehow he's managed to
summarize what is actually a very
complex character in a piece of music
which is extraordinary
well that's going to do it we hope you
enjoyed this deeper look into
expeditions wrong we can't wait for you
to have your own unique adventures
playing our game
we do regular devstreams on twitch and
we also have dev diaries on our
community side so we'd love for you to
join us there and take part in the
conversation we also have facebook we
have twitter we have discord so there
are plenty of opportunities to get
plugged in and learn more
the only off-road racing franchise to
feature bikes atvs and utvs is back with
its eighth installment mx vs atv legends
this time around the team at rainbow
studios wants players to know what it
feels like to become a world famous
professional motocross rider building a
career competing through a real-life mx
calendar plus story elements like
invitationals and sponsorship
opportunities this in addition to the
new trails mode which takes riders
across various outdoor environments as
well as squad-based multiplayer gameplay
supported by rainbow's new server
infrastructure here's a first look at
what it's like to go from amateur to pro
to motocross legends
[Music]
is
[Music]
this is how legends are made
this is how legends are made
[Music]
this is
this is how legends are made
[Music]
this
[Music]
is superpower 3 aims to be one of the
most complete geopolitical simulations
out there set in the contemporary world
you'll play a country and influence
political social economic and war
simulations grand strategy teams up with
real time strategy to bring you the
ultimate chance to go back and make the
tough calls in real life situations you
might even do better than the pros or
much much worse
[Music]
because we've all had to wait and for
much too long
to be finally heard
around this country and spreading all
over the world now
what do we see
incompetence imbeciles weak leaders not
able to rise up to the times
our times
this is why as a new generation takes
over
everyone should be fully aware of one
thing
today is not about me
today is about all of us
today
is about our movement
there are millions of us out there
joining our cause
and it is together
bound by this cherished heritage that we
will show them who we are
we've only
just begun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
up next we've got elix 2 the sci-fi
action rpg set in a vintage open world
if that didn't get your engines going
maybe this will there will be fireballs
there will be flamethrowers there will
be the return of a certain jet pack
magalon is waiting for you and needs
uniting once again step into jax's shoes
and save the world less talking more
showing
i know that an unknown foe will come
soon
[Music]
all my efforts to prepare humanity for
this impending danger
or for naught
humans forget
we can't ignore the signs we have to be
prepared we have to take care of
ourselves above anything else
this is a war
now
don't be such a buzz kill man grab a
beer and relax
listen the threat is real
the aware will come and we haven't got
much time left
we ignore the signs there'll be no
future for us yeah i know but maybe
maybe you're getting caught up in this
too
it's probably not that important right
now
kyah i'm doing this for all of us
we have to do something
in case you haven't noticed i have other
things to worry about and i could really
use some support here
[Music]
coming to you from hemimoto games is
jagged alliance three the game combines
turn-based tactics with the best parts
of strategy you operate a mercenary
organization out of africa and you'll
choose your band of heroes or less
heroic freelancers from a pool of
numerous characters each with
individualized personalities and skill
sets for the people who remember ivan
yes he'll be there too this world reacts
to your decisions and the fate of the
country rests on your shoulders alone
because of course it does
looks clear
the diamond should be upstairs
soldiers
stop there is nowhere to go
he didn't know
what
why is
retrieving diamonds
what anymore
while we are doing now man
improvised
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all so much for joining us
today i hope you had a great time and
are just as hyped as we are for all
those upcoming games
but wait i almost forgot
legend claims that the wishes of those
with pure hearts can be granted with a
vial of mermaid tears
are you ready kids
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
you